leaders are absolutely determined to
remain united and work closely together
s27 we reconfirmed that britain's
withdrawal from the european union must
be orderly and there will be no
negotiations of any kind until the UK
formally notifies its intention to
withdraw we hope to have the UK as a
close partner in the future leaders made
it crystal clear today that access to
the single market requires acceptance of
all four freedoms including the freedom
of movement there will be no single
market a la carte we also discussed the
fact that there are too many people in
Europe who are unhappy with the current
state of affairs and who expect us to do
better many recalled that for the Kate
Europe was bringing hope and that you
have a responsibility to return to that
those who want to have we access to our
internal market they have to implement
Four Freedoms without exception and I
have to add without neurosis we are
expressing the view that of course you
be newly needs further reforms but it's
about speeding up the report it's not
about adding reforms to already existing
reforms the general view was that there
would be no treaty change